the Emir of Qatar has landed in Tehran
he's the first national leader to visit
the Iranian capital since the
assassination of Iranian general Qasem
Soleimani
by the US Qatar has called for a
peaceful solution to regional tensions
Qatar is close to the US but also has
strong ties with Iran sharing the
world's largest gas field or more on all
of this we're going to bring in acid bag
now in Tehran and let's start with these
protesters a certain tell us about the
anger that you're seeing on the streets
there yes many people have been angry
and frustrated after the revolutionary
died admitted that it was their missile
that brought down the Ukrainian air line
now it was up came after days of denial
from the government but it wasn't just
denied it was statements made by the
speaker the sport government
spokesperson the Foreign Ministry
spokesperson saying that the United
States was lying we said we heard them
say that the Western media was engaged
in suspicious propaganda we heard them
saying that all this was false rumors we
even had the head of the Aviation
Authority here
say that you are scientifically
impossible and illogical that a missile
had brought down the airline but
yesterday the Revolutionary Guard came
out the president came out and said that
it was a mistake it was human error and
they apologized and the Revolutionary
Guard the head of the Revolutionary
Guard aerospace division took two state
TV and apologized and explained what
happened but people are still angry they
want accountability and they want
justice and last night there were some
protests in there on mania two
university campuses and we know that
they were there chanting anti-government
and anti Revolutionary Guard statements
but also the British ambassador to Iran
was active that protest that vigil they
started off as a vigil and turned into a
protest and he was detained for a short
while and then released now he's tweeted
out this morning and what he said was he
confirmed that he was at the vigil to
pay his respects some of the victims
were British he said he wasn't at the
protest but he left five minutes after
five minutes when people started
chanting he was detained half an hour
later after
and he said that arresting diplomats is
of course illegal in all countries
I said critical to all of this is
accountability in justice we're hearing
that from the international community
the demand from Ukraine the demand from
Canada and of course as you pointed out
the demands that are coming from the
Iranian people as well
what would justice and accountability
look like well President rouhani issued
a statement yesterday last night and he
said that this should be a thorough
investigation that we should know how
this happened and the reason behind it
the individuals identified and
prosecuted and the Iranian people should
know everything about the situation now
we know there was a closed-door meeting
this morning between members of
parliament and the head of the Islamic
Revolutionary Guard now we've had some
statements come out after that meeting
we know that the head of the
Revolutionary Guard was asked about why
the airspace was not closed down
considering that just hours before Iran
had five missiles at us targets in Iraq
now he said that the survey that the
Revolutionary Guard are not in charge of
civilian flights and the IRGC doesn't
have any responsibility to stop them but
that won't satisfy a lot of people
because someone should have made the
decision to close down the airspace so
there will be an investigation we
understand that security national
security committee will be putting
together a report also regional
countries are concerned as you said the
Emir of Qatar is visiting and the
foreign minister was here just last week
asking for restraint and trying to calm
the situation after thank you rested by
joining us live there from Tehran